[Applause]
mike pompeo has spent the dying days of
the trump administration trying to
burnish its
and his foreign policy credentials in a
speech at washington's national press
club
he claimed an old enemy had found
support from another
long-time u.s adversary al qaeda
has a new home base it is the islamic
republic
of iran as a result
bin laden's wicked creation is poised to
gain strength
and capabilities we ignore this
iran al-qaeda nexus at our own peril
we need to acknowledge it we must
confront it indeed we must
defeat it president donald trump pulled
out of the iran nuclear deal in 2018
finally fulfilling an election promise
his administration then pursued a
campaign it described as maximum
pressure
aimed at forcing terran back to the
negotiating table
imposing tough sanctions but others who
negotiated the deal refused to leave
with the americans
pompeo insists other countries must wake
up to the danger
the iranians though have dismissed
american claims the foreign minister
tweeting
that pompeo was pathetically ending his
disastrous career
with more warmongering lies relations
between
washington and tehran have deteriorated
even further in the last 12 months
in january last year the u.s carried out
the targeted killing of qasim sulaimani
the head of iran's revolutionary guard
al-qud's force
in baghdad and the u.s aircraft carrier
is currently in the region
responding to what the americans call
threats
pompeo has claimed links between iran
and al qaeda in the past
without providing any firm evidence one
expert
says this is more of the same if there
was any evidence whatsoever
they would have rolled that out very
quickly and very early in order to
further justify the maximum pressure
campaign against iran they didn't mike
pompeo has been cranking up the pressure
on iran in recent weeks and has even
announced
fresh sanctions those close to joe biden
believe that this is calculated
the intention to make it more difficult
for him to re-engage with iran
when he takes over on january the
twentieth
alan fisher al-jazeera at the white
house